hi everyone
- the daily homeroom livestream we're
doing it a little bit earlier than
normal because we have a guest that we
really wanted to talk to who is
available to normal
first of all for those you're wondering
this new location they are cutting down
trees outside of my normal location and
my kids are getting a little bit loud
downstairs as well before before we get
into the conversation I will make the
announcement that I always make
reminding folks that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization we only
exist because we have support from folks
like yourself special call-out to
several corporations who stepped up in
the last several months especially when
they found out we're running it as
deficit and we were trying to step up
for the kovin response and our cost went
up so special thanks to Bank of America
google.org fastly 80 and Novartis so
with that I am excited to jump into our
conversation we have bill Lewis today
someone who I've known for some time and
have always enjoyed our conversation and
I think there's a lot of things going on
in the world but I would love to get
Bill's perspective on so bill great to
have you my pleasure
great to be here thank you so I guess
just to just to introduce you you're the
co-chairman of Lazard a very
well-respected
investment bank in on Wall Street and
you know I think there's a couple given
your background there's many things we
can talk about today you know there's
the economy there's obviously what's
going on in America around race
relations and policing but may be a good
place to start is you know tell us a
little bit about your journey you know
did you always think that you would one
day become co-chair of Lazard yes no I
know we don't have a lot of time and in
my estimation you're right there are a
lot of things we can talk about I guess
I got it's good yeah I guess there are a
lot of things that we can talk about I
hope we spend a fair amount of time
talking about race in America because I
think we have not seen anything like
this since 1968
that's probably a good place for me to
start I grew up in Richmond Virginia the
capital of the Confederacy I went to
segregated schools in Richmond for the
first eight years after nine years
kindergarten through the eighth grade as
most people know brown v board of
education was decided by a Supreme Court
in 1954 and Richmond really didn't
comply with that until 1970 so 16 years
later in 1970 the journey that I'm on
now really took a different turn I
received a full scholarship through an
organization called a better chance ABC
to to go off to boarding school and I
went to Phillips Academy in Andover
Massachusetts for four years and after
Andover I went to Harvard College
majoring in economics and then I went to
Wall Street where I started Morgan
Stanley and a two-year analyst program
and then I'm at the Harvard Business
School and then I came back to Morgan
Stanley I spent 24 years at Morgan
Stanley ultimately running their global
banking business and then I joined
Lazard
where I've been for the last 16 years so
that's sort of one part of the journey
along the way I've been involved in lots
of not-for-profits many around education
I've sat on the board I sat on the board
of Andover for 16 years I now sit on the
board of uncommon charter schools the
largest charter in the Northeast I said
on the board and the positive foundation
I said on the board the Research
Alliance for New York City Public
Schools I about to go on the board of
foundation for child care child
development and most recently I joined
the board of the city fund an
organization that has been founded by
Reed Hastings and and John Arnold in
addition I
on the board of the New York City Police
Foundation which is an interesting
contrast to the organization that I
chair a co-chair some time ago called
the Legal Defense Fund which is actually
the organization that started was
started by Thurgood Marshall so it's
sort of gone full circle in that regard
and I said on the board of the New York
Presbyterian Hospital which has become
the largest hospital system dillmouth
kovat in the United States so in a
nutshell that has been my journey that
is how I'm spending my time these days
in addition to talking to CEOs or
regular basis
I can't get you
sorry I had muted it cuz my
five-year-old was screaming downstairs
so I didn't own it but no I was saying
no that's I think that that's really
helpful for people to appreciate just
the breadth of your perspective that
you've had especially in some of these
organizations you're now on maybe you
know maybe getting straight to the
moment we're in you know you mentioned
that we haven't seen something like this
since 1968 what do you think it is about
now that that that is that is different
maybe or or that that everything is
culminating to ahead and and what do you
think this moment will mean I think not
to be slipped but we really have Steve
Jobs to think to think in terms of why
this moment is different the iPhone we
saw two terrible incidents two very
different incidents that were captured
on videotape but but two very powerful
incidents are Julie the the callous
murder of Jewish floored by the police
officer in Minneapolis was different I
don't think any of us or certainly not a
lot of us have ever seen someone killed
on live television I don't care who you
are where you are
that was a moment in time that was a
modern day lynching and
and and and that has touched a nerve
unlike anything else that we've seen in
this country the second incident that
was captured on video was the was the
scene at Central Park which is literally
right across the street from me that in
a lot of ways was just as powerful not
to downplay the significance of a murder
but there was an african-american man
who went to Harvard
like I did like my son does now my
youngest son does now that was a man who
was talking very peacefully and very
respectfully to a woman who was
violating our laws here in New York and
there was a woman who is known
figuratively by virtually everybody in
in New York City everybody in the world
of finance this was a 40 year old
well-educated highly educated woman who
works for who worked for a a major
financial institution so this was a
person that all of us metaphorically
deal with every day and and she was very
thoughtful it was all premeditated she
told this African American man what she
was going to do how she was going to lie
and use and weaponized race if you will
and watching those two videos made us
all realize in very different ways that
we are in a moment in time that we need
to stop and take stock of who we are and
what we're trying to accomplish as a
country and why not a lot has changed
since 1968 when we last had very very
violent social unrest in our country and
and I think that is really powerful
haven't you know we were all aware of
all of the different things that have
been happening over the last several
weeks or months or frankly years but I
think those kind of the bookends of
those two issues because I think that's
right that second one it didn't result
in someone's death but it it
it very transparently showed that people
people that we would expect much better
of frankly that they were in many ways I
mean you know just add context to it you
know this is a woman who was threatening
to call the police and she knew that you
know in and kind of this she said she
said she would get the benefit of the
doubt and if she if she told the police
that he was threatening her that you
know it would be it could be a scary
thing for him the what do you think you
know to your point the you know having
everyone having smartphones it shed some
light on this but obviously for every
incident that is recorded there's
probably another hundred that don't get
recorded how do you think this plays out
like so the first step is to be able to
recognize that it is happening to have
documentation so we are there where do
you think this goes what are the reforms
that you think need to happen you know
and some of them could be legal reform
is it something in how policemen are
trained but there's other things that
are I guess I just could only describe
as cultural reform so so how do you
think it plays out or should play out so
so that's that's that's a great question
and and let me sort of grab a little bit
first of all let me say that I don't
think and I could be naive and I could
be proven wrong I don't think for every
one incident that has captured on video
there are a hundred that are not because
that would suggest that that we've only
seen one percent of the sort of violence
and indifference that exists and I don't
think I'll country is that bad but but
but i but I take your point
we are not almost by definition we can't
possibly see and know everything that is
going on and even as we saw in the case
of the of the jogger in Georgia being
murdered even when there is video
there's no guarantee that that that
we're going to see it so look I think
in terms of framing where we go from
here I think there will be several
versions of actions of a transformation
of our society and I'm not a big tech
person witness how difficult it was for
me to dial into your call but what we
saw in some cases what we what we are
seeing is what I call version 1.0 of
other reckoning and that is our leading
institutions whether they're colleges
high schools businesses political
offices or all putting out statements of
support and acknowledgement that that
this time is different and our voices
must be heard and that is a bare minimum
you look at every professional sports
organization in this country I think 31
of 32 NFL football teams have put out
statements and so forth and so on
so version 1.0 largely revolves around
words version 2.0 which is also which is
also underway involves checking the box
around monetary donations encouraging
employees to give to their favorite
charity that could address some of these
issues with companies matching those
donations version 3.0 involves really
substantial financial contributions
Morgan Stanley where I worked for a long
time
sent a five million dollar check over to
the Legal Defense Fund third Goods
organization last week and we're going
to see a lot more of that Bank of
America announced that it's going to
spend a billion dollars on doing this
but ultimately version 4.0 is going to
involve more than
writing checks and more than speaking
words it's going to involve taking
substantive transformative action around
change and it's gonna have to be
something that can be measured I will
make a small wager to anybody that in in
one year's time
every media outlet every television
station streaming service every
newspaper will have a highly promoted
feature program and it'll be and it'll
be some version of the following title
Memorial Day 2021 the one year
anniversary of the death the murder of
George Florida what has changed and I
can guarantee you that everybody will
look back and asked what has changed and
I think forward-thinking leaders will
start thinking about that now the one
thing that the business community does
extremely well probably better than any
other institution in our country and
that is we measure stuff we measure
everything if it's important to us we
measure it if it's important to us we
hold people accountable if people sort
of accomplish their goals and do what we
have set up to measure then they get
rewarded they get promoted and get paid
they get rewarded if they don't then
they're dealt with as well they get
fired they get demoted or what-have-you
and so the business community is already
having some soul-searching discussions
around what are we going to measure and
how it'll look different a year from now
what will be our contribution to
continuing the dialogues that have
started I should have said also that
even before version 1.0 the most basic
thing that has to happen before we go
anywhere will be honest conversations
and getting out of your comfort zone I
have told all my partners at lazar there
are only three african-american partners
that Mazar the rest of white i've told
every single one of them that they need
to go through their contacts and
identify seven or ten seventy ten
african-americans whom they know they
may know him well they may not know him
well they may have been high school
classmates they may you know see I'm
occasionally in churches somewhere but
they need to call them and they just
need to listen and hear and try to
understand what is going on at the in
this moment in time it's a very very
uncomfortable conversation to have it's
probably not uncomfortable for the first
two or three people you call because
you've known them for a long time
but to try to reach out to somebody that
you haven't talked to in 10 15 years and
say tell me what you're experiencing
right now is something that I think
should be a required moral exercise for
for everybody in this country and by the
way I'm in turn reaching out to the
hundreds and hundreds of people that I
have interacted with the thousands of
people that I've interacted with over my
lifetime to say I'm calling you because
I know you're thinking about these
issues and I know you're wondering what
can you do and when it's super helpful
and you know if we imagine ourselves a
year in the future and we you know we're
having this conversation again I agree
with you there probably will be shows to
that nature you know we're getting
questions off of Facebook and and and
YouTube on you know what are the levers
that hopefully will change by then you
know Maya
bholaraam says you know what are your
thoughts on people reacting this and the
other extreme defending police actually
Susan Garcia Dominguez I said I'm so you
have a relationship with some of the
police groups inside of New York you
know what what is obviously emotions are
running very high right now but what are
the levers that you would like to see
changed a year from now or two years
from now or ten years from now well
first of all let's just talk a minute
defunding the police I think
unfortunately excuse me
that's a charged word I think people
need to appreciate that
by default our police departments have
been asked to do a lot of things and
fundamentally our police are here to
protect and to serve us but our police
are not social workers and our police
are not health care workers early in New
York City we asked our police to enforce
social distancing we asked our and
that's a charged word and force police
aren't trained to enforce social
distancing and so if you look at the
budgets of the police department and you
look at some of the things that police
have been asked to do so for instance a
lot was made of us shutting down our
subway system for the first time in a
hundred plus years in order to clean it
every night between the hours of 1:00
o'clock and 5:00 o'clock in the morning
police were asked to go into the subway
to to assist the homeless and to remove
the homeless in order to disinfect those
trains it's questionable as to whether
or not that's a job for the police what
the police decided to do was to take
nurses into the into the subway stations
with them and homeless advocates with
them to to figure out what to do with
the homeless people in the subway
stations that is money that the police
department is spending on services that
fundamentally aren't policing and and
and so when we say defunding what we're
really talking about what I think people
are talking about is reallocating money
that has been parked with the police
department to cover a whole range of
services that aren't policing in in
their orientation by the way as an
analogy
well the largest part of the New York
City budget is on education we spend
thirty billion dollars of our 19 billion
dollar budget on education but we do a
lot more in our public schools and
educate we serve more bills in the New
York City Public Schools and any other
institution other than the US military
so we are a huge provider of food we
provide in effect shelter we provide
daycare and so one could argue that
those funds should really be under
health and service health and where fair
housing or what have you so I don't
think the funding in itself of the
police department or the Education
Department is what we're talking about
we're really talking about allowing the
police to do what they're supposed to do
in a smart and intelligent and
thoughtful way in a respectful way now
having said that there are very very
very specific things that should be
addressed as they relate to policing
reform the current head of the Legal
Defense Fund is is a woman named
sherrilyn Ifill I fi ll she just wrote a
very detailed article in Slate Magazine
it's about three days old she lists
probably 15 very specific and reasonable
reforms for our nation's Police
Department I would encourage everybody
to read those those those reforms
they're very sensible they are in the
best interest of our country if you ask
what should change within the next year
I would start there because those are
actionable items and those acting on
those items will tell us what side are
you on and and and not acting on those
items
similarly tell us what side are you on
that's that's super valuable and you're
just - I hom I'm definitely gonna take a
look at that right after this is it the
nature of it is you know things like
improving training is it things like I'm
is easier for Sheriff to let someone go
who's under disciplinary action and
things like that we start with the most
sensible and the most basic there should
be a database a national database on all
law-enforcement officials if you get
fired for killing somebody illegally in
New York City by using a chokehold you
shouldn't be able to go across the river
and get rehired in in Newark New Jersey
right now there is no way for us to
track those kind of offenses on a
nationwide basis that's a huge loophole
in and the enforcement of civil rights
in dealing with in justices we have
something in New York
that's called section 58 it revolves
around disclosing certain information
certain disciplinary information on all
cops right now that is private
information many cities make that
information public we are talking about
training we are talking about
de-escalation I like to say that every
cop should wake up every morning and
before he or she brushes his teeth
should repeat the word de-escalation ten
times that should be the mantra the vast
vast majority of encounters between the
police and our citizens should result in
some sort of de-escalation and New York
City spends a lot of time training its
officers on how to de-escalate and by
the way distillation is much easier when
the police officer looks very much like
the community in which he's policing and
so and it looks very different
when the police officer does not look
like the community in which he's
policing police officers are meant to be
Guardians not warriors and and and that
is sort of a critical part of our
training but I don't have the list in
front of me and I haven't committed it
to memory which I probably should but
but I would just advise people to just
pull it up it's very you could easily
pull it up online now it's super helpful
and you know we have any some questions
here where you know Maximilian
Bissonnette about well they're asking
for a question around systemic racism
well lesson on systemic racism one kind
of gathering but this this term systemic
racism is something we're hearing a lot
of now what how do you think that
manifests itself in addition it's
obviously broader than this notion of
policing because a lot of what you just
described are kind of it seems like very
pragmatic policies to have better
accountability better transparency
better training up for police officers
you know the whole de-escalation thing
makes a lot of sense but that still
doesn't seem to necessarily get at the
heart of of potentially you know
systemic racism and and and how systemic
racism it depends how you define it is
you know pervades more of society what
does that term mean to you and and how
do you get at that what we saw in the
case of the Central Park murder was
systemic racism there I am sure that
that 40 year old graduate of the
University of Chicago living in one of
the most liberal communities in the
United States the Upper West Side of
Manhattan working at one of the highest
profiled financial services company in
the world exposed on a regular basis to
a very very diverse community and
population very very thoughtfully
announced in advance how she was gonna
lie
to the police department about what was
unfolding in that Park
in broad daylight by the way that could
have resulted in a death of that
african-american man because if the
police has shown up and it was sort of
his word against her word and if he had
done anything move his hand very quickly
or what have you
he could have been dead that is the raw
definition of systemic racism and and
and and and so I don't know how we deal
with that until we have had an ongoing
and sustained national conversation
around race and I know the people like
Bryan Stevenson at the equal justice
Institute and Darren Walker at the Ford
Foundation are trying to facilitate that
but in this moment in time I think we
are talking about a series an ongoing
series of discussions around racism and
how do we get here coming back to what
you do so well and that is education I
think there is a huge opportunity a huge
a must do for us to think about how we
put this topic into our classrooms early
how do we instruct our teachers to have
this discussion with four year olds and
five year olds and six years old six
year olds we are amazingly creative and
thoughtful about using technology and
the like to solve some really really
really tough education questions I think
that we're gonna have to think really
really differently about
we get the discussion and how we get
exercises and how we teach the whole
concept of systemic racism I don't know
I don't have an answer for that but I
would say that I believe the vast
majority of parents were shocked when
they heard the videotape of the woman in
Central Park and and I believe that the
vast majority of parents would be
appalled if if if they knew that they
had friends who could talk like that
well god forbid their children could
talk like this and so I pose this as a
real opportunity and a real challenge
for our educators
and here I can tell you
sorry no my bad my kids are making a
ridiculous amount of noise down there
just playing the piano and screaming and
anyway this is you know this is probably
working from home I've threatened did
someone know the my five year old is
under the impression that the police are
you know and this goes maybe to your
previous point maybe the police are
invoked a little bit too much but I've
definitely threatened him sometimes the
I guess maybe you know some final words
there's obviously a lot of people with a
lot of energy right now around it what
you know I like this idea of the very
tangible things mentioned in Slate
article and I think our team has just
put the link to that article and the
message boards on Facebook and YouTube
for everyone to look at it well but what
should happen to the energy around the
protest you know there is a world where
they say hey you know here the five
reforms we need to see there's a world
where they say we're just going to keep
doing it because people need to see it
you know there might be elements in the
protest of even also economic anger or
displacement that are mixed in with the
the racial systemic racism well how do
you think the protests are going involve
and what advice would you have for
people who are on the streets how should
that evolve we had massive protests
civil unrest in the early 60s and that
led to the Voting Rights Act and the
Civil Rights Act one in 1964 and one in
1965 the immediate result of these
protests should lead to people coming
out to vote in November and making
changes from top to the bottom
people chose not to vote in 2016 and for
any number of reasons and there are
consequences to not voting the most
basic right that we all have and the
most basic obligation that we all have
is to translate protests into action and
the most basic action that we can take
revolves around voting and voting at the
federal level voting at the state level
and voting at the local level divorces
are there unlike any that that most of
the people on this call have ever seen
and the will is there and the vast vast
vast majority of the protests protesters
in excess of probably 99% are protesting
peacefully and they need to continue
this peaceful protest right up through
Election Day in November the other thing
that people around the country should be
doing is going to visit in mass their
police chiefs and their mayors and
demanding an answer to the following
question how can we be assured that what
happened in Minneapolis will never
happen in our city it could be a city of
10,000 people it could be a city of a
hundred thousand people but people need
to get into the Nitty Gritty and
understand if what they saw happening in
Minneapolis could happen in their their
hometown but I think so the most
important thing that that that everybody
can do is translate protests into voting
the business community will be doing a
lot of things and I'm sure the
not-for-profit world will be doing a lot
of things and the education
community will be doing a lot of things
they will all be very very different but
the one thing that we can all do which
is identical and it is a requirement it
is a right it is an obligation is to
vote yeah no I think those are very
actionable doable things for for anyone
anyone listening well bill you know
whatever these conversations and you
know I learned a lot in the last 2530
minutes that we've had to chat to chat
and I know a lot of the folks watching
on YouTube and Facebook have as well
it's always you know I think you have a
gift for kind of cutting through issues
quite incisively so thank you for that
and I hope we can do this again
especially is you know our world
continues to evolve we really appreciate
this conversation it's been my pleasure
I guess I've got a question I didn't
realize we're on YouTube or Facebook how
do I send that to my kids oh well the
link for sure I my apologies if I didn't
tell you that we are reaping live for
the last 25 minutes yeah you've been
doing great yeah I knew it was live I
just didn't know what it was live to so
I appreciate that
okay okay well you know sometimes the
best conversations are the ones where
you don't think there's a lot of folks
watching but no I from the feedback on
Facebook and YouTube I think a lot of
people have really appreciated your your
thoughts and I think you know it's
interesting because we've been hearing
about this you know almost continuously
on the news for several weeks now but
you know a lot of what you said in the
last twenty or thirty minutes was you
know it kind of sparked some AHA's in my
mind and I don't think I'm alone so and
it was very actionable intangible which
I think it's really really valuable
right now so I appreciate that
well I enjoyed it thank you very much
for having me thanks so much bill okay
take care
so thanks thanks everyone for joining
today I don't know if you heard some of
my kids screaming downstairs my
apologies for that but you know where
we're keeping it real here then we're
cutting trees outside of my other place
I am so that's why I'm the noise your
place right
now but you know I if you're like me I
always find I've had you know the
privilege of having several
conversations with Bill over the years
on things like education and equity and
as as I would have guessed you know he
really cut through the issues I thought
in a very useful way so hopefully you
enjoy that tomorrow we're going to
continue the conversation we're going to
have Fareed Zakaria I'm sure that
conversation will also get into a lot of
what's going on into the war in the
world and then on let's see tomorrow and
then I think on Thursday it's all a blur
to me we're going to have well later
this week we're going to have Francis
Ford Coppola to talk about creativity
and probably things like narratives and
and how to make sense with the world as
well so thanks for everyone for joining
and I look forward to seeing all of you
on future live streams
you